hello everyone thank you very much for
joining us for the google claude
schmitt and the session we are going to
do now is about
machine learning
so i'm damien roux i'm a strong
marine senior at google
i'll explain a little bit
the story of a machine learning for
google as we experienced it and
explain to you what happened
afterwards we will have accenture and diplomats
who will also give their testimony
on this phenomenon
today the dip the machine  learning
and in particular the dip their ding I
will explain to you in more detail what
it is you surely already use it on a
daily basis for example at the bottom right
when I go up it is the
google translate application you are able to do it
in  aude and offline in your
phone if you want so that if
you are abroad in a place where
there is no network can
photograph a menu for example a
lodging in frankfurt two three
weeks ago I  take a picture of the menu and
I finally know what I'm going to eat without
a practical connection it was
sausages potatoes and cheese there was
nothing fantastic but it still helps
machine learning quite
a bit it's clearly a buzzword  you will
find it in many articles and
in many themes for us google
it is not at all a need to
really try this message there that I would
like to pass on to you today on
the screen you have sundar  pichai our
sineo he makes the following observation
that roughly every ten years there is a
revolution in the world of pickpocketing
there were computers there was internet there
was mobile and for a long time google
was mobile first  say that if
they developed an application we
focused first on the
mobile experience and a posteriori on the experience
of the stops let's say and now we
consider that we are a machine
learning company and by dint of you that's enough
paradoxical because if v
ou watched sergei breen's speech to our
founders in davos at the beginning of the year he
was invited to a panel on machine
learning and what they say and it's
nice to invite me because
indeed at google  we do a
lot of it but you would have asked me the
question a few years ago I would have had
great difficulty
telling you that machine learning
was really a pact and at google
he says it was very difficult to know
he says to the  he era neural networks
already existed in the
years we around 58 we had created a
neural network with 400 neurons which
reproduced an eye with 20 by 20
pixels but in terms of applications
in industry there was  no
youth fund did not have the capacity it
did not work and yet in google
x which the idea at the time he had
people very very good in machine
learning
for example he had jeff told
us who came to see him  and
show her a picture of singing telling her
beats on sight now machine learning
is able to recognize that it's a
cat in this photo and sergey says well
I thought it was great because obviously
a cat is half the content
of the internet but concretely for
google what's the point  it will be useful to us
or will it be used it was
not very clear for him is the reason
why it was not very clear
is that what has really changed is
the dip learning so it  is a family
of machine learning
I'm going to put it in parallel with what
we're going to call human learning
there you have a page from a
galilee's notebook what they were doing at the time
what are we  done all in terms of
scientific close da we observe a
phenomenon we take measures based
on this observation we will create a
theory for example physical equations in
addition and then we will
implement algorithms that
implement this theory so
typically if you want to solve a
problem  today  i where you are
what you have to do is first
observe the problem
the analysis is in theory the theorized and
after you can implement it in
terms of work so for example
what does it mean if i  think
very simple problem where I would like that
if I give you the coordinates of a
point its xs we y you predict me its
color is it going to be blue or
is it going to be orange our instinct
is quite clear  we will draw a straight line
and we will say everything that is below
in the lower left corner
if you give me a coordinate that is
under this straight line they consider that it is
orange
on the other hand if you give me a
coordinate that is in  top right I
will consider that it is blue and saas
and it is this equation that I will
give to my developers typically
for him
here is the algorithm that
you need to implement and now I have a
program that  solves this problem the
machine learning it is very different there
what I  e shows on the screen it's tencer
flowboard so you can go on the
internet
it's a fairly minimal neural network
that runs in your browser
what happens there on the left and on the right
you see the inputs that I give to the
networks  of neurons there the neural network
it has a neuron it's hard to do less
but with a neuron
it is able to solve this problem
there so I give it x and y as input and
I tell it how you solve that and on your
own  he's going to find a right
I animate him paef so trust me
he doesn't do that in brute force brute
force what does that mean he does
n't try all the possibilities of the
right by finding which is the
best
he starts from a  right and then they
want to optimize as
they go until they find what they
consider to be an optimum to
solve this problem there you see
the very different approach there no
time did I tell my network to  neurons
that the solution to lettr  you're a straight line
he found it on his own in another
problem a little bit different but if
now my points were distributed
in a circle in this case there as a
human very easily I recognize
the shape of a circle and I decide to  my
young developers the equation of a
circle and that is what must be implemented
in the neural network
there is another way of doing it we can
do future engineering
what does that mean what does that mean we will choose the
points  input rather than giving it
x and y
you notice that on the left I have chosen
xo squared and y squared why
because it is the equation of the circle so there
always with a single neuron
I am able to solve  this problem
there as a human it's very
satisfying
we recognize the circle it's perfect
it's our theoretical habits we like to
see this perfection nevertheless
got fired engineer insa was used for what
it's basically a  part of the work of
data scientists which is ident  ify the
type of data that will
solve the problem to speed it up
so that it is allowed irrelevant
so typically someone who is in
the who knows a particular business well
he knows which variable will
be relevant or not on the other hand
if  I had absolutely no
idea if I don't know the equation we
insert how I'm going to do
you notice on the left I'm always going to
give that x and y
I said after all I have no intuition
on the fact  that x squared y squared
is better on the other hand I added
neurons in the middle each neuron in
the simplicity of this neural network
each neuron roughly it's a straight line
is what you get at the end it  is
n't an ideal perfect circle but it
's something that works just as well
to solve the problem
it's a set of lines that
basically defines the circle and if I add
neurons I'll increase its precision so
what you see  there it is that the network
of neurons he is very pragmatic he does
n't bother with the human race of knowing
whether to do something ideal or
not and with the addition of power
I was still able to solve this problem
there now if you imagine this
problem which  is on the left and I'm
asking you for the equation of that because I
need the theory to ask my
devs to do there all of a sudden
it's much more of a hassle
you're going to spend a lot more
time theorizing this  problem there on the other hand in
machine learning
I spend no time theorizing and I
will give a lot more
power I just have to add layers of
neurons and power to
solve the problem there in an
acceptable way for my problem what I
will tell you  show there it's google deep
mind it's an example that dates from 2014
there what we do is that we give this
atari game basically to a
neural network which has been configured to be
able to  playing st he gets that
pi
xels he has absolutely no idea what a pixel
means he has all the pixels
he is told he must optimize the score
is every time I give you a
screen you tell me if you go left to
right leaned on  a button on the
gamepad that's all that it's 10
minutes the first ten minutes of play
good it's basically like I my parents in
this game there it's chaotic
they don't necessarily understand the
rules you have to  be fast you have to
understand after two hours
we will see it in a few moments
machine learning will learn from its
mistakes
there it is a case that we call
it is a case of machine learning it is
able to learn from it  even so
it's a bit special case see
there roughly he understood that
the small palace had to remain vertical to
the ball etc. it was already very used to it
but that they develop
it develops its months  and
probably if you had asked
a developer for a program to play
this game there c  that's probably the
theory you gave him wanted ready
analysis or and the ball and making
sure the palate is always below
the ball is like that you don't lose and that
's a type of program now
machine learning  always the same
you just gave him two more hours
of training and two more years of
training will make him discover
that there is a theory that allows him to
win faster a way to
win faster
he digs  a small tunnel on an overhang
which blocks the ball behind and there the
mission which was to optimize the
score as quickly as possible and fills
much faster
so what is interesting there is that
if I asked my developers
now is this  that you can
improve the program for me and make his
bass and redevelop a new
theory and redo a new program
so it's something very
different now that's even
stronger what I show on  the right
is the set of games
played by this same neural network each
time you see a blue tip it
means that the neural network and
is better than a program developed
specifically for this game there the line
horizontal above this is when
the neural network back then was better
than a human playing this game there so
that gives you an idea now if
you ask if you still think back to
this idea of developers having to make
program  specific
there he should make a
specific program for each game while the
neural network is the same that we
will re-train on each game so the
gain the lever once the message
is once you have found  a
problem that has a typology
potentially the work you
would have done in machine learning will
allow you to solve a whole
typology of problems which is
much stronger than a program
developed on an organ  who will have to
redo his program each time one
of the other questions that I find
interesting is why machine
learning is particularly good at
certain games why it is
particularly because between
when he makes a decision is the
consequence of this decision  you see
that at the breakout this time and minimum
if I don't move my little palace immediately
the ball passes and the game is over
on the other hand if I play chess and
I push a pawn between the moment when I
pay my error the  moment of the action and
the moment when I pay for my mistake there the
time is particularly long and therefore
this correlation is difficult to make the
longer the time is between the action and
the consequence the more time the machine learning
will have difficulty in  make this
connection so that's very powerful what
's behind so if I summarize a
little bit and it's one of the clichés that
we often give we say the models in
machine learning
we  had existed for a long time and
this is what sergueï brienza tells us existed
for a long time,
however what has changed a lot in
recent years is the
computing power and the volume of data that we have
that has enormously changed
the powerful and  you see better
why google found itself on the
path of machine learning very early
in our history because the
data we have a lot of
why we have this application - which
have more than a billion users
in the thermal baths in the  service that we have
for applications that are used
not in companies but by
individuals after anonymization of the
data we can use them to
do machine learning
so we have a set of data that is
quite large and that allows you to
do  parallel obviously we have a
lot of infrastructure, the google
business club in particular, which
allows us to run this machine
learning so we had a playground
quite quickly there what you  see on the
left of the screen
it's the first google server and on the
right it's an example of a datacenter
today i think you can
see the scale first and then a little
bit maybe from where  come the colors
google we have the impression that it was
inspired by something in the team of
data that we have it's like
many companies
we have data that we have recovered for
a specific purpose the images  google maps
for google street view
was above all to help
people locate themselves on the map and
give context, but when a few years
later we realized that we
could do machine learning on it
we were able  retrieve street names
validate the directions of traffic
the signs a whole set of information
which without it would have been very complicated to
retrieve we did not have to make an
additional collection effort we had
this information there that's another
message of a machine learning in
general
is when we build  a data lake
is an opportunity to use
data that you have collected
for other purposes as an idea this is
an example google maps
there what I present on the screen and I
go in detail and just  2 is that
today machine learning at
google you find it in all
of its solutions there almost all
google products have had machine learning
and if you think back to what it said
would be breen
a few years ago he says  5
and 6 years ago I didn't have this vision
I couldn't imagine
it's one of the difficulties of machine
learning I think it's that at the beginning it
's hard to see where is what  'you
can apply it for yourself on the one hand and it does
n't work every time either
what is important is to be able to
try quickly so first example
in google search the best
improvement of search
and google algorithms  in recent years it's
been machine learning
it's pretty crazy because if  you want to
find a company where there are
probably the best minds
thinking about how to create
search, index
big data or other
algorithmically by creating a theory it
was at google and you see that it
there was a need to do a
management challenge a cultural change
within the company
support people to explain
this new approach to them
the ability to implement it too and
now we are going to have people who
apparently could have said I lost a
ski since now knowing how to theorize
on research
after all in a certain way
vis-à-vis a machine learning it has
very little interest on the other hand what has
enormous value
it is able to know what it is  the
right interesting input data to
be able to qualify or not you
see this change in terms of
qualification and the interest that there may
be for the migration to machine
learning
d  second example that I'm going to give
is alpha go so alpha kids and
it's a bit of a sequel to when I
said earlier about video games
between action and consequence the longer the
time the more it's  is hard legault
it's probably one of the games where this
time and the longest it's possible
to imagine so alpha go turning
mean gardene google I've put you
on the left some dates and
people who have been beaten as and when
as and
and since we decided to stop
playing gault what is interesting in this
match there it is between lyss idole it is the
third match I believe and alpha go
has just played a blow on the fourth
line on  the edge of the screen
the black dot the presenters and the
players their reaction to this move it
was good alpha go made a mistake
in practice alfano still won the
match
why everyone said we
made a mistake  error the reason is that
all the theories of hugo for 1500
years  and some say it's a
mistake to play on that line there and
so no one was doing it so what
's interesting here is you see
khalfa go playing against
himself learning from existing matches was
able to  go against the intuition of
all the matches that existed and from which
he learned one and to open a new
path in the beautiful today if you
go to asia in korea in particular and in
china where go is particularly
popular
you will find  people who say
they follow the new
strategic theory of alpha go to play
on this fourth line so is
that creativity for me
it's less creativity than being
able to go beyond it  of certain
human tickets to solve
problems another example the implementation
we had at google is in the
datacenters google consumes roughly the
energy consumption of the city of
los angeles in one year
80% of this consumption is the
datacenters a datacenter it consumes a
lot to cool
so here we used machine learning
to help us regulate everything that is
air conditioning within a datacenter
I find that it is a very
interesting problem if we think back to the
human starting point  learning if I had wanted to solve
this problem there I should have taken the
Newtonian and diffusion theories
of the heat room
model my entire datacenter knowing that
each server is a small radiator
so there the model explodes  extremely
quickly it is insoluble in
classical physics in the learning model that
he was able to do is to
stimulate it
with sufficient precision to
allow energy savings of around
40%
so we see that  there is a typology of
problems certain problems or really
the classic approach is limited and that
allows us to go further
to solve this problem there it is very
different from the classic approach of
c  alcul when we have a theoretical approach
we often have an approach to the
comma and we will go to the end of the
calculation and this is what allows to
do everything that is cpu and gpu
when you do machine learning in
general  you don't have you don't go
down to that level of precision
you need to go very quickly to
manipulate matrices but not so much to
keep ten decimal places
so if a volume of data a
quantity that is done but for  a
data calculation it is better to
be able to go quickly than to
be precise
so what google invented is the
tpe the tender processor and unites so
it is a completely different form of calculation
and specialized in the
manipulation of matrix for algebra
nor tunes for machine learning
I put a figure that may not speak to you
180 teraflops
and that's what is capable of making
this machine down there the photo is
the  equivalent of roughly 10 petaflo  ps
to put you in perspective
today in france and it is the
sixteenth in the world the biggest
calculators it is the total society
that he is very proud he is the 16th
in the world
his name is dipped in  it is in pau in
the in the search for oil we
need to do a lot of calculations
to estimate where there can
be oil this datacenter this hp
it is therefore who is the 16th in the world he
does  5 petaflops there what I have at the bottom
right which is much smaller it's around
10 petaflops
of course it's a comparison which is
unfair why because as
I explained what total does in pau  it is
too precise calculations
with other approaches but for
machine learning
if we confined to this problem there you
can see that it is a very
very powerful problem and a
very powerful calculation capacity which is there behind also
at the  beyond the hardware but I find that
this hardware part is
important because  that sometimes
it seems that google only knows soft
and besides I may have told you
something else sure about this tp hulin at the
beginning when we did machine
learning at google we did it by
saying we  has peaks in our data
centers when youtube is used at
certain times of the day
then these peaks go down again and therefore in
the 2000s at the beginning of the 2000s
what was said about it is well when the
datacenters are not used it is  a
good time to run
machine learning algorithms on
classic infrastructures from
2003 our projections have shown that if
the machine launches if machine
learning develop as we think and as
we have experienced it we would be unable to manage
everything  this need for calculations has it therefore since
2003 we identified a need for a
tpe and today it is our second
generation and if a rather
unique approach so it is its thoughts its
continues its industrialists and it
is something  who has  was identified quite
early in parallel we are working a lot to
make machine learning let's say to
democratize it so tencer for c1 it is
the development platform that we have
used internally a lot of one
of the most popular that we have used
we decided  to make it in open source
so that means you can use it for
free if on github you can
contribute we made it in November
2015 very quickly it became a
reference tool for developing
machine learning
why 1 because they had  a
level of abstraction that was very
pleasant for people in a few
lines you were doing the equivalent of
many more lines per year and a
defense of themes on flo is that it
allows you to work on your
perimeter locally if you  you want and
in a few instructions to switch
to the club which is expensive in
machine learning it is the
training part when you give it the
data you ask for  to create
the model
once you have the
machine learning model using it it doesn't
cost anyone confident and that's
why I can run google
translate on my phone so tencer
fuzzy it's a way to democratize
the  machine learning
is surely the most
advanced way of doing machine learning
this is where you will customize as much as
possible at the other end of the spectrum and the next
session
will tell you a lot more about it that's
all  which is a country where you do
n't need to know what
machine learning is you give it an
image and they analyze an image for
you there i give you an example
this line of dots it's the
inception model  v3 from google
this machine learning model is the
one it's one of those that we use
for image recognition
I want to show you one to
show you that it's still quite
complicated when you hear about it  of a
machine learning as I do
by  times bronzers to okay it's
just layers that follow one another it's
enough to take a lot of time but
full of data we have the result one year
what I'm going up behind these are
years of research to improve the
type of  neural network structures
tricks for coordinates
and data work that's saying so
toussaint it allows you to recognize
an image at the end in the same way
as an api
which is interesting when you do
times on  flo is that you can
take this model there which is aerial
on flo removed the last layer of
neurons and reprogrammed it for example
at the bottom left you could say I
am a company where I would like
someone  take a picture of a part
is automatically known to air and
kindly give him these images there you
withdrawal is only on the last
layer so there we are talking about a few
hours of theoretical work it is very
very low and you  have a new
model which is c  able to do that I
'm going to finish with two customer examples an
example with airbus which had the
problem of satellite image
recognition wholesale they sell satellite images
is a decoy challenge is that if there
is snow
they can sell  the image but if a
cloud they can't sell the image if
a cloud on the photo it's not worth
their recognition their
classic recognition algorithm had
trouble when there was a conflict between
snow and clouds using  and in
this case he was forced to resort
to human using tencer flo per year
I was a bit fast using tel on
flo they were able to reduce the
error rate from 11% to 3%
that's it  It's one thing for me what
interests me in this example is that
they did this in three months three
months for a problem that is also
critical for their company on a
problem on which they have worked
for years and years  years
I think it's an investment  weaving
which is very interesting and for me
it is one of the key messages of a ning machine,
especially on the google platform
which eiffel splendor if you try
something you will quickly get a
result which will or will not confirm
your idea of  continue three months
of investing
it's a game that's worth it very
clearly another example on the other
end of the spectrum is the question I
'd like you to ask yourselves behind this
is me in my daily life in
my  work
at what time do I have data is a
label applied to this data there what is
it why I am asking this
question here because this is how
you are going to find the youth km
around you who lay  which are
messy pieces of machine learning,
for example,
are you given a file in
your work and your job is to say whether the
file is accepted or not well, that's
typically a set of data
is a  label accept  or not I'm
simplifying but at the beginning it's hard to
see places in our life where we have
that there it's a Japanese student
whose parents have a
cucumber plantation and he the idea he had
it was  classified the cucumbers so
he found a really beautiful example
I take a contest photo and I
decide what type it is is it
extra large medium small
can we sell it or not and then he
has  developed an automatic sorter
that sorts cucumbers based on their
image and grades all that he was able to
hang out in the club because that's
where his partying is intensive but
once they had developed his model no
more need for the club
it runs on a very straw breed which
is a microcomputer and everything works
very well
so really the question that I would
like you to ask yourselves I suggested
asking where in my life I have to
give it labels is
potentially one worth stocking up on  this
data this label there to do
machine learning to give you one
last example and I'll end on
this this is an example that we all have in
our lives every time we throw
something away unless you don't do
sorting is not good if you
sort every time you throw
something away you are
wondering is it something
that is recycled or is it
something that goes to compost
that's a machine learning problem
someone to develop something or
automatically
it's done here so
I'm summarizing and I'm going to invite laurent from
accenture to give you other
examples that have been developed with our
friends thank you very much  a pick up
hello everyone I switch well so
first of all thank you for welcoming me here
when we talk about artificial intelligence
we think of all the examples we
saw earlier I have a lot
of  examples on cucumbers did
that too in the indust  rie
that's called quality control and
are solutions that we deploy more and
more every day
and finally this gift
is that beyond the virtual assistants
of facial recognition systems
in airports or  for
satellite recognition biometrics that we have
just seen its solutions today
they are mature
they are ready to be deployed to
our customers to transform their
business model to address and create
new services
and that is the reason c  is the reason for
my speech today is to
show you some of these examples and see
how we can we can accelerate on
it's thanks to
artificial intelligence for us
artificial intelligence are systems which is
qu  they make it possible to
capture information to understand it to act
on certain training stocks and then
to learn over time either to
increase human activity or to
work independently
ome artificial intelligence we have seen
it is a real
technological revolution i liked the example of
sergei brin just now who said we
did not necessarily see it coming and it is
a bit like this  that we see on the
succession of new technological waves
they are increasingly rapid
closer together in time and they
are more and more impactful they have
they have an increasingly strong impact
so there is a real phenomenon of  amplitude
and I believe that this morning also had the
first ready the person who
presented first to talk about the fact that one it's
difficult to see what is going to be the
next wave and composes disrupt and
the companies that existed in 2008
today in  2018 on the telephone part,
the two main players don't necessarily exist and we have to
think about those who are disruptive all the time
if we want to
be present in the years to come and
if we're going to be out of two, says play a
bigger role and finally  it's here
what is our role and that's where we see
by interviewing a certain number of our
clients so we interview we have a
study called la tête ville jeune
and we interview about 6,000
managers each year and 85%
leaders we interviewed this
year tell us in the years to come
we are going to invest massively
in artificial intelligence so well
it's not necessarily very, very big
news for the people who are
in this room but what is
interesting  it's that if we had asked
the question three years ago they
rightly tell us maybe it was
n't the time
now if we do it now and
if we don't do it right away it will be
too late
so there is  a real awareness
that this wave has arrived it will
move everything that today we have to
invest and it's the right time to
do it because there is a transition
to artificial intelligence which
affects all sectors
another  stitch  what is critical in
understanding artificial intelligence
is that it
completely changes our relationship with
technology
sixty years ago we were finally talking
to the machine adjusting to the
way its language thirty years ago by
having and  a keyboard a mouse
then we had touchscreens then
we had smartphones and now we
can talk to the machine and it's the
machine that adjusts to humans so
it's a real transformation in the
way we  interacts with
machines and by 2024 it is believed that
more and more of the interfaces that we
use today in our everyday lives
will disappear and be
replaced by these voice interfaces
everyone starts from imagery  satellite
you're going to see all the examples of the
holes in the picture it's called the
airbus presentation on ad it's a
very very nice use case
why it's a very nice
use case because it  there is a lot of
data and that  we can
extract information that is relevant for
government actors or
simply for administrations have
for industry this
information it can be refreshed
over time and we can
seek more and more information
relevant
so here
it is the case of a project on which we are
working we have worked which has made it possible
to identify certain types of buildings
thanks to the ears of corn on google we have been able to be
relevant over time and give
value to its  customers that they were
working on satellite imagery
another example that I
find just a little bit disruptive
compared to what we have seen so far
is the use of ears with google
for then there  this is the breeding ground for an
augmented technician augmented technician
we are going to talk to you I am going to talk to you about
cockroaches and the reason why I
am going to talk to you about cockroaches today
is that if you have a
cockroach problem at home that  'East  what's happening
in the old world so three years ago
when companies hadn't
necessarily been invested in his services the
tooth in the old world
when you had a cockroach problem
what was happening is you have a
technician who comes to your house this
technician and runs after the cockroach he
catches the cockroach he puts it in a
box
he takes the email box a number
the address of the customer to whom he and he
sends this cockroach to a lab and the
laboratory analyzes the  cockroach tell you
what type of cockroach it is you do
n't need to collect it then the
technician comes back with the product
suitable for this cockroach to kill the
descendants of the original cockroach and so
the family has had time to
grow  meanwhile thanks to
google
thanks to these techniques we
've been talking about since this morning finally you see a
cockroach you take a picture of this
cockroach directly we have the possibility
of identifying what type of cockroach
we have at home in addition  also advantage
of allowing to identify that in this
type of building at this location
there is this type of cockroach and we can
intervene with the right product
which avoids us a round trip and
which prevents the family of cockroaches from
developing  which is unfortunate for
him but which is much more pleasant for
the end customer and the last case
which seemed relevant to us today
is the first tic of the call center
call centers it's a it's a
request that we see more and more
with large volumes so there the
use case I wanted to mention to you
today we work today
with large governments on
why I put to bed at the service of the
citizen we  works with government agencies
we know that the processing time can
be relatively long I think of
another example when I moved from France
to California I wanted to transform
but I admit I wanted to adapt my my
printer to my printer in the US
it was a french printer
he adapted it to us i spoke i spent
six hours with a call center
it's not an experience you want
to live every day it's not an
experience  which is very rewarding and
finally it is an experience that we
could automate
immediately in a consistent way
with the new services that are available to
us, we can clearly see that
on the one hand we can automate
a  charge of the channel of the text of
the chat emails we can have an nlp engine which
takes care of all these
requests
it is to interpret them and then we
could have
automation routines which will
seek information on the systems
and who know how to provide the right answer
to the customer in a relatively short time
and these are solutions that we
therefore deploy in the example of
the European administration whose game
I was talking about earlier we are at 85%
improvement of  customer quality 82%
of the resolution time of a ticket and
finally a great reduction beyond the
quantity of errors in particular on
relatively complex tasks so by
finally talking to you about a technician
increased by a call center and also
of a 4 young computer life on
satellite imagery but we have a
certain number of cases on the quality of
the image I think we have a
relatively representative sample of what the
services can do today
are solutions  that we are implementing in france
and in europe
on a large scale and I think that in the
room there are a certain number of experts
in artificial intelligence but we
are there in any case to accompany
the large groups to help them
get through this  cap is accelerated
towards artificial intelligence thank you I
'm going to give the floor to 20 cents
he's going to show you a little bit what
he does with his with his team
thank you laurent hello to all thank you
for being there
so yes so me  I knew  is here
today to show that AI is in
fact also within everyone's reach so
we saw a lot of things this afternoon
it was quite rich already we saw what
machine learning was
we saw  that there were tools for that
the specialized APIs we have also seen
concrete application cases
unfortunately we find we have
diplomacy it still remains today
a technology which is within the reach
only of experts and if you
today  indoors you
already have two ideas as in league could
transform your job I think
that unfortunately the question to
ask you is how do I start
what do I do I'm here to show
that in fact it's going well  happen
so I'm vincent of being I'm
the city of the diplomatic and our
mission is really to democratize the
dip their ning applied to images
and videos
our goal is really I
allow you yourself to create ai that
will be adapted to your emails  this
means that senior who will be able
to recognize the concepts that
are important to you
and it is also an AI that will be
trained on your own data in order to
maximize performance for example
so that they can adapt to
specific shooting conditions
or simply the types of
data you have whether it is rgb from
the radar office infrared
these data that you send to us
obviously they remain they are
your property they remain the rest we
distribute them to no one  else but the
models and annotations that are
produced through our
diplomatic platform they are also
your property because we know that in
fact these are texts and a
technology that will profoundly change
your processes and your profession and that it  it's
important that you have your hands on it
like that it's a bit of a theory
I actually wanted to go into practice fairly quickly
what I'm proposing to
you is you to show u  n little when it happens
on our platform to be able to
train an artificial intelligence yourself
I will take an example the example of the
hello world of dip learning the example
of a marketplace for example of fashion
which wants to recognize four types of
bags  different from backpacks
travel bags handbags and
clutch bags which are small bags that you
hold your hand for the sun who don't know
a so it's ok it's going to go around quite
quickly it's  is a video and we
suppose you will see that we have already
applauded the images of the marketplace
one of the images of bags on our
platform and that we have already entered on the
left the different the four types
of the beauty that we  wants to recognize therefore
the four types of bags that I am
recognized so therefore it works great
so we have the images which are claude and
the four labels on the left and we will
start by doing what we must
always start doing at the beginning
i.e. trained the algor  ithme and
explain to him what we want to recognize so
the platform suggests images to us
and we will click on the correct answer we
will click on the type of bag rings
we are going to do this for about
twenty d  image and we can already
start training a first
artificial intelligence so there it's
brilliant a model which is
very light it's a linear model
it's going fast and we get a
performance of 39% it's not terrible
since chance would have made 25%
there is a one in four chance so we
continue is lamentable it is that
once we have trained a first
artificial intelligence
the platform does not suggest giving them
to chance it will offer us the
images that  are the most confusing,
that is to say the images that annoy the
most artificial intelligence these
images will provide him with the
most information in fact which will
make it possible to reduce no images to note
so we train them once again we
have  48% that  progresses and we see for
example the backpack we at 0% on it and
well it does not matter the platform to
adapt it will try to offer you
what it thinks are backpacks
to be able to catch up on
this place of that that we continue a
little bit here
I reassure you it's accelerated we do
n't have a rating expert who clicks at
this speed so here we are at 56% and
we will reach 67
here we are so we can go  see a bit
what it looks like so these are the images
that have not yet been annotated we will
sort that we will ask him to
show us what they think are the
travel bags a phase that you draw the
images or  the least safe are
travel bags and at the bottom are the images
or the safest are travel bags
it works quite well there as not
misunderstood we can go to see another
example we can go to see
handbags  the same up these are the images
where it is less safe and below the images
where it is the safest  sure so that's not bad
it works quite well but we haven't
yet trained deep learning in fact
at that time we just trained a
linear model which is a very small
very light model here we are going to
train  other first neural networks so
you'll see we took a little
inspiration from windows for the
somewhat jerky progress bars we
thought it was good it takes a little
time it will always take longer in
fact the  diploma because those
models that are heavier you will
see it's worth it because we
go from 67% to 84% at the
mouse level there at the bottom right so it
's still a significant improvement
20%  almost just by changing the type
of model by switching to neural networks
and we will deploy it, that is to
say transform it into an api
that's the country finally the interface of
the apei we will be able  send take an
image from google for example she sent
our to pay agree  t to create includes
a random bag
we stick it in the country only for those
who program it's basically a fund
for those who don't program basically
it's a way of Internet users and act
with a program and it responds  so
then it's not clear but it answers that
it's a purse with
99% certainty or that's not bad it works well
and trained our first
artificial intelligence have about
three minutes that's when  even quite
effective once it's done suddenly
we have an API that we can integrate into
our application at home and at this
point the interest is not yet over
since the interest of our platform to
also be to bring together a  once
your 1st ai and in production
the production images or your
artificial intelligence that you
created is a little annoyed she doesn't know
what to answer
she's not really sure of herself it's
going to come back to the platform and you
'll be able to  view images
are possibly  re anomalies maybe
things you don't expect in
our training center and you
'll be able to correct that led to a
second artificial intelligence
version 2 possibly add
a label because you would
n't have thought they had  such type of
bags and more here is improved
as the life of your product
progresses the artificial intelligence
associated with it so that's it was quite
easy it's a platform everything that's
missing everything you need to  to be able to
train your first
artificial intelligence easily it's
data your data then there is more
than a hotel we can also provide a
rating service also needs but
it's gone then for suddenly to me if
I go I have  a few cases so far
I had presented to inspire you a
little to give you ideas these
are the kinds of things we can
do with our platform so
there was an example of the marketplace to
change there  I took the marketplace
of real estate and I asked
the algorithm to display the images
yes finally it thinks that there are
some canonical examples of combat swimming pool
who understood it well and interests for example
for a  mark and pay it is
really to be able to help
sellers who upload their goods for sale
to be automatically tagged
that's right it's very important for
a marketplace because it
allows him to improve his test at  its
referencing in google is therefore
to bring more traffic to its
marketplace moreover it also therefore makes it possible
to improve internal research and
to improve the interface
finally the user experience on the
marketplace it obviously also works
if you have  a more traditional e-commerce site
I now take
a little more exotic examples so the
detection of defects typical to
the appearance of
wholesale drones has made it possible to be able to cast
scan spells a little mass  if of
the infrastructure of buildings by
collecting a lot of images at very
high resolutions which makes it possible to
detect in fact quite easily a defect
in the east in the infrastructures
and corrected them preventively
the problem with that is that well  we end
up with terabytes of data
to analyze and suddenly the experts
who are supposed to recognize these defects
are a bit overwhelmed
in case of use I apply
artificial intelligence it's
really to be able to reduce the amount
of data  to look at a sent to the
experts that the images where there is a
suspicion of defect it makes it possible
to ensure that they have much less
work which concentrates on the
places the images where they have
added values is really to value their
work that
this notion of focusing on the images also works, for example,
we have a
suspicion of a defect, for example on
the production lines in the
factory or, for example, in medicine.  cine
for legged donkeys who have to
look at a lot of images
to look for cancerous cells
we could reduce the amount of
images they have looked at even at the same
time perhaps increase their attention
because they have more or less  of images
so they are more attentive
comment on their effectiveness last case a
little
I will present I was able a lot of
time so I did not spend a lot of
time on images
in fact we can do more than
classification with  deep learning we
can also detect objects which
i.e. located in the image the
objects and if in addition we are
working on a video we can follow
them through the video in its part do things to me
very interesting as an
account and not an object that passes in
a video know their type
recognize urban areas for
example in satellite images this is
their characteristic detect
anomalies or behavior  s dangerous
for example we are able to do all
that with a platform quite easily
and I now wanted to tell you a
little about what is under the hood
I presented to you the facade under the hood
so you should know that diplomatic was
founded there  three years ago at the time we
did not yet we do not know yet far from
it since it did not exist
and we assure there is therefore with interest its
development and roughly when the
stable version was released there is  some
time it was pretty clear to us
that we had to port all our code
on it because it was the first
time that we finally saw a real
complete diploma platform
you know we had the assurance that it
would be maintained  and which in addition was
flexible and that is very important for
a datacenter to have a tool that is
flexible to be able to
quickly bury on these models and
quickly find the way to
model its problem as a bonus point
more and more  suddenly it runs on
different environments
the gpu the mobile the tpe and it allows us
to really deploy our algorithms a
little where we want it also allows us
to scale up that must be very good
with their emails suddenly that  it was
very important I wanted to end with a
small example of the life of a data does
nothing typical tistes basically you have to know
that another säntis he needs about
every two days to train
for five hours these
neural networks because that's about the
time it takes and if he wants to run
three trainings in parallel
because he has to test three different types of
parameters so
he needs three times four
gpus let's say  by training it
needs a dozen gpus for
five hours every other day
for a tenth of the time so you
see a bit of you i'm coming
to so it works plus if we have a
single data scientist if we have any  together they
will fight for  having the gpus to
know who is going there anyway gpus and
how many they will be able to use
so it's no longer a problem if you
have claude hamel who is ploughing at
your baccalaureate end allow you to
elastically
launch stubborn throwing training  at the request
of adapting the other infrastructures at the
request of the data calves it's a test
so to finish sorry to finish only a
few tackles ways tensor flow more
claudel for us it's really the
combo that makes it possible to
finally optimize  we can use all the
power of the ning diploma in a drastic way
in the meantime it still requires
no engineering to put all that in its
bin n is for example the men
of airbus that they made in three months
I think that  'we could have done it in
three days with our platform
so if you have any ideas
come and see us will know how to answer them
thank you very much
[Applause]